ah
[Música]
si hay un país que ha sabido aprovechar
su posición geoestratégica y su
influencia política es turquía sobre
todo desde que comenzó el conflicto en
ucrania en 2014 y la posterior invasión
de rusia en el este ucraniano en febrero
de este año desde hace varios años
turquía busca recuperar su posición de
potencia mundial y regional de cara al
2023 año en el que se cumple el primer
centenario de la fundación de la
república turca moderna que fue fundada
por mustafa kemal atatürk en el marco de
ese plan de política exterior ankara ha
intentado jugar a ser un actor relevante
en el escenario internacional ser muy
importante en la toma de decisiones y
por ejemplo la guerra de ucrania así
como lo fue también la guerra en siria
pues es el escenario perfecto para hacer
una pieza clave a nivel internacional
pero pocos entienden qué papel quiere
jugar un país mediador tomar partido en
alguno de los bandos apoya los valores
democráticos occidentales o no de que el
lado está turquía
pues este país turquía o turquía como se
le conoce ahora a nivel internacional es
un puente entre medio oriente entre el
mundo musulmán y occidente
estambul que es la gran metrópolis turca
no es la capital la capital es ankara es
un cruce de caminos es un paso obligado
desde el mar negro como ustedes lo ven
en la parte de arriba de la gráfica a
través del estrecho de los dardanelos al
estrecho del bósforo que da paso al mar
de mármara y de ahí al mar egeo y al
mundo entero es un paso obligado para
los barcos que zarpan desde el sur de
rusia y también desde otros países como
bulgaria rumanía y también ucrania
pues veamos algunas de las acciones
recientes que ha tenido turquía en el
escenario internacionales se ha mostrado
entonces como un mediador ofreció a la
ciudad de estambul y también a su
capital ankara como un lugar para
conversaciones entre ucrania y rusia
intenta mostrarse como un país neutral
ante moscú porque tiene claros intereses
con este país pero en el conflicto en el
este de europa juega a dos bandas le
vende drones a ucrania y le compara
misiles a rusia pese a que ha habido un
fuerte rechazo por parte de la unión
europea y de eeuu también varias
ciudades turcas son ahora el refugio de
varios exiliados rusos periodistas
pensadores actores artistas deportistas
ciudadanos del común que no están de
acuerdo con el kremlin y mucho menos con
la guerra en ucrania han abandonado el
país y han comenzado un nuevo camino en
tierras turcas
ante las sanciones por parte de bruselas
y también de washington los bancos
turcos se han convertido en el destino
de varias fortunas y de capitales rusos
este país depende también del gas ruso
pese a que complementa su suministro de
gas con gas procedente de irán y también
de su aliado estratégico en el cáucaso
azerbaiyán y más recientemente como lo
hemos visto en las noticias a nivel
mundial pues amenazó con volver a
impedir la adhesión de suecia y
finlandia la otan si estos países no
cumplen con esos protocolos acordados
entre los tres países en el marco de la
reunión que hubo en la ciudad de madrid
en españa
a que juega entonces turquía de que
parte de la historia quiere estar que
tan importante puede ser su papel en una
posible solución al conflicto ucraniano
y como puede ser su relación con el
mundo occidental que tanto influye ya en
esa zona de periferia en el medio
oriente en países como irak en el
cáucaso en la cuenca del mediterráneo lo
vamos a analizar hoy en el debate de
france 24 por eso hemos invitado a
nuestra invitada que se encuentra en la
ciudad de mexico ella se conecta desde
la capital mexicana ya es erika ruiz
sandoval internacionalista profesora
visitante del centro de investigación y
docencia y económicas y desde la ciudad
de madrid se conecta pablo del amor él
es coordinador de arroba descifrar
guerra también es analista geopolítico y
también es analista de cooperación
internacional ustedes nuestros
televidentes hacen parte por supuesto de
esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y comentarios en las redes
sociales estamos como ustedes ya lo
saben en instagram en twitter y en
facebook también no se encuentran como
france24
sant y luego mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 20 4
en youtube también pueden seguir nuestra
señal en streaming saludamos también
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos escuchan en nuestro podcast los
invito para que escuchen todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa que están
disponibles en el podcast en spotify en
dice gentium y pues bueno ya después de
haber hecho esta introducción este breve
contexto de la situación que se está
presentando allí en la zona de
influencia de turquía le doy paso
entonces a nuestra invitada a erika en
la ciudad de méxico gracias por haber
estado por estar con nosotros en el
programa y el punto de partida para
conocer posiciones sobre este tema erika
qué papel está jugando entonces turquía
en el contexto internacional
específicamente en la guerra de ucrania
qué tal muchas gracias turquía está
tratando de
desempeñar el papel que más le conviene
que finalmente vivir un poco a la
indefinición y tratar de sacar el máximo
jugo y el máximo partido a su posición
geográfica que es de gran importancia
estratégica
turquía está viendo que tanto puede
jalar la cuerda para conseguir algunas
concesiones que necesita no solamente
por la necesidad de posicionarse ante
este nuevo acomodo geopolítico sino
también porque tiene elecciones internas
en puerta muy pronto entonces turquía
generalmente él hace de su política
exterior una herramienta para convencer
a los votantes del poder que puede tener
un gobierno y particularmente un
gobierno como el el de erdogán sí que
está en serios aprietos porque turquía
está pasando por una crisis muy severa
y le trasladó la misma pregunta pablo en
la ciudad de madrid en la capital
española pablo bienvenido al programa y
qué papel está jugando este país en
términos estratégicos en el contexto de
esta guerra en ucrania
bueno como les ha comentado
anteriormente en turquía funciona como
una especie de balance entre ambos
bandos porque tiene intereses tanto con
ucrania como esa venta de drones pero
también tres comerciales económicos como
temp con intereses con rusia se ha
comentado también que ha comprado el
sistemas antiaéreos
s-400 rusos que por derecho les
granjearon sanciones por parte de eeuu
la cuestión es que con rusia tiene
varios acuerdos a nivel de siria libia y
el cáucaso lo que hace que tampoco pueda
enemistarse con con la potencia rusa a
pesar de ser un país no tan ahora mismo
lo que está buscando evidentemente con
la cumbre de la otan es intentar ganar
beneficios para sí mismo no solamente a
cuestiones internas y en lo que
próximamente anunciar el presidente de
logan de hecho que iba a realizar una
operación en el norte de siria contra
los los luchadores kurdos y que tiene
una forma también de presionar a la otan
para que apoyo o digamos que nos
sancione esa operación militar que va a
realizar según sus propias palabras del
presidente próximamente
pablo continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa desde el punto de
vista de la otan desde el punto de vista
de eeuu y de la unión europea que mirada
tienen de turquía entendiendo ya estas
múltiples bandas en las que juega
entendiendo esa buena relación que tiene
con moscú y sobre todo en que se ha
mostrado muy cercano con ucrania desde
que comenzó el conflicto en 2014 y sobre
todo de que comenzó la invasión en
febrero de este año es un jugador
internacional en el que occidente estos
tres actores que nombré otan en bruselas
y washington pueden confiar
bueno porque hay que entender que es un
país militarmente muy importante y unos
ejércitos no preparados de la otan
aparte de lo que se ha comentado antes
es un puente entre asia europa a parte
de yo creo que hay que dividir en dentro
de la otan los países que son más
favorables a turquía por ejemplo españa
que mantienen unas relaciones con ankara
pero luego hay países como francia y
sobre todo grecia que mantienen muchas
tensiones debido a cuestiones de
soberanía territorial sobre las islas
del egeo
diferencia eso luego el tema de bruselas
evidentemente también hay tensiones
porque hay que tener en cuenta que
turquía es uno de los garantes
fronterizos de las fronteras europeas
porque de europa le paga dinero millones
a turquía para que cuál es su fronteras
para que no entre los refugiados pero
sin embargo la política tan asertiva con
que ha tenido de turquía en los últimos
años de política exterior que ha minado
los intereses roperos también ha hecho
que haya cada vez más recelo dentro de
europa y la otan pero claro al final es
es un país que se necesita por lo que he
comentado antes y por eso 70 mantener
ese balance para que no digamos que las
tensiones no suban vamos a hacer lo
mismo intenta que no que no se suba las
tensiones porque comparte digamos
intereses en varios escenarios de sus
fronteras y tampoco le interesa ganar
otro enemigo por tanto le interesa que
turquía se mantenga un tanto neutral y
por eso juegan a estas bandas tanto
moscú como ankara la cual es su opinión
erika y escaló un poco más la pregunta
la sacó del contexto europeo y la llevó
hasta washington esa relación washington
ankara muy tirante muy difícil
sobre todo desde que salió desde que
llegó el presidente by the end al poder
cuando hubo este cambio de presidente en
eeuu era una relación muy distinta a la
que había con donald trump y también
después de hechos como el intento de
golpe de estado al presidente eduardo
gun eso sembró también hay un poco de
malestar a nivel internacional y la
relación con el presidente de logan
sí claro al final lo que estamos viendo
es
que erdogán está haciendo todo lo
posible por
componer un poco su relación con eeuu
que desde él como bien dice usted la
llegada de biden se ha tensado mucho más
antes podía hablar directamente por
teléfono cuando quisiera con el
presidente de trump al final eran
políticos parecidos un tanto cuanto
populistas los dos en ese sentido pues
vaivenes muy muy diferente
ante la pregunta de si se puede confiar
en turquía pues yo creo que estamos en
momentos en donde se nos recuerda que el
mundo se mueve más por intereses que por
valores pero ahí también hay un gran
obstáculo para turquía y yo creo que
tanto washington como bruselas han
querido ver en turquía un aliado que se
puede transformar que puede aceptar los
valores democráticos etcétera y con
erdogán pues éstos han ido
deteriorándose progresivamente entonces
supongo que están teniendo muchos
problemas porque al poner en la balanza
que prefieren no si es una cuestión de
valores o es una cuestión de compartir
narrativas de compartir
los grandes ideales sobre la democracia
y demás o las cuestiones más prácticas
de orden absolutamente militar de orden
de poder duro pues es difícil decir qué
hacer con turquía no no se nos puede
olvidar tampoco que si como decía ya
nuestro compañero turquía pues trata de
ser el que le resuelve un poco a europa
el tema de los refugiados pero también
ha sido país candidato a la unión
europea es decir en algún punto ha
estado donde hoy ha peleado tanto
ucrania por estar no entonces creo que
eso también nos recuerda que que parte
de los intentos de occidente y sobre
todo de la unión europea es pues ser una
gran zanahoria para que estos países se
transformen y apuesten más por el estado
de derecho por la separación de poderes
es decir por todos los valores liberales
enfoquémonos erika en la relación entre
ankara y que ya lo mencionábamos es muy
cercana a ucrania considera a turquía un
gran aliado estratégicamente a nivel
militar le ha aportado mucho lo
mencionamos con esta industria de drones
ya vamos a hablar en específico esa
industria militar turca que se
desarrolló impresionantemente en sólo
diez años en ucrania está acusando a
rusia de haber robado trigo y de
haberlos puesto en varios de estos sacos
y toneladas de granos cerca de 7.000
toneladas en diferentes barcos que han
salido del puerto ucraniano de verdi ans
que está ocupado por rusia y tienen que
cruzar por los estrechos turcos se está
presionando al gobierno turco para que
los detenga ya hay uno que está anclado
en el norte de turquía y está siendo
investigado por las autoridades para
determinar si de verdad es trigo robado
por rusia aquí qué tanta presión
internacional hay sobre el gobierno
turco en torno a este tema sobre todo
con esa premura que hay a nivel mundial
porque estamos a la vuelta de la esquina
de una emergencia alimentaria
precisamente por la falta de cereales y
granos procedentes de ucrania
yo creo que la presión va a ser mucha
creo que turquía está ahí también
tratando de desempeñar un papel clave
por ahora moscú ha dicho que no que en
el barco bueno tendrá bandera rusa pero
no es nuestro etcétera es decir están
creando una suerte de cortina de humo
sobre sobre estos cargamentos pero es un
tema tremendamente sensible por la
crisis en puerta si no es que ha
empezado ya en muchos países del mundo
que están necesitando estos granos y
creo que aquí también se puede tensar un
poco de más la cuerda con con ucrania
una cosa es que ucrania haya visto
favorable que turquía ofreciera
estambul o ankara para ser sede de
conversaciones podemos y otra cosa es
que no se tome una decisión en la
capital turca sobre de qué va de qué
lado están o sea finalmente en este tipo
de conflicto creo que va a ser muy
difícil seguir jugando a dos bandas o
buscar una supuesta neutralidad llegar a
un punto donde las definiciones se van a
exigir y se van a exigir fuerte
llegó un momento en que tal parece que
turquía llegó un callejón sin salida
pablo le va a tocar tomar una decisión
frente al paso de estos barcos y
claramente la decisión que tome va a
generar malestar o en kiev o en moscú
que le conviene más a turquía en este
escenario sin salida desde mi punto de
vista que no acostumbro a expresar mi
opinión pero es una decisión complicada
la que tienen ahora entre las manos los
turcos
sí bueno de hecho al principio de la
guerra turquía ya anunció que nadie iba
para ningún barco ni parte de la otan ni
parte de rusia ni parte de ucrania que
iba a pasar por el estrecho que decir
que es una decisión que ya tomó en el
principio lo que pasa es que ahora está
recibiendo presión y de hecho turquía
también ha querido que es el trigo salga
de por parte de ucrania después del
puerto de odessa y por parte también de
que salgado trigo por parte de rusia lo
que pasa es que evidentemente la
situación entre ucrania y rusia pues
evidentemente no es muy filtrar un
acuerdo cuando dos países están en
guerra en una guerra que es muy cruenta
y que los dos países pues no no quieren
ceder ni un punto aparte de ello yo creo
que es evidentemente que tú quiera decir
muchas presiones pero creo que no es
ajena a ese tipo de presiones se la he
visto en muchas crisis internacionales
aparte de ellos yo creo que
personalmente que es lo que le interesa
más a
turquía en este punto es intentar no
enemistarse demasiado con moscú a lo
mejor si dejar pasar esos barcos pero es
seguir a lo mejor suministrando de
material militar aunque digamos un quid
pro quo lo que intentar por una parte no
enfadar demasiado a rusia pero por otra
parte como muestra de buena voluntad
también seguir enviando material militar
a ucrania para que pueda defenderse del
ataque ruso pero que llegamos acá lo
mejor sería una de las posiciones que
más le podría interesar ankara no
intentar mantener cuanto lo más grave
que pueda esa neutralidad esa
neutralidad en pub lo importante poner
aquí en contexto para la audiencia en
américa latina' la industria militar ya
hemos mencionado que les suministra
drones de avanzada tecnología al
ejército ucraniano que han sido claves
por ejemplo en la defensa de la ciudad
de kiev y en puntos estratégicos en el
este de ucrania esta es una industria
relativamente nueva es uno de los
grandes orgullos de la gestión del
presidente de erdogán a haber
desarrollado esta industria militar
prácticamente el país se abastece por
completo
de material bélico pero la mayoría de
ellos todavía depende de partes hechas
fuera de las fronteras turcas esto pues
le genera algunos problemas
si llega a haber algunas sanciones
contra este país como ya ha habido por
ejemplo cuando le compro misiles a rusia
pero qué se puede decir de esta
industria que tanto es esto un as bajo
la manga para el gobierno turco para
jugarlo en cualquier momento
bueno en lo que pasa es que turquía
lleva exportando stv este tipo de armas
los drones desde hace ya varios años
sobre todo en guerras que han sido
bastante favorables para este tipo de
armas como puede ser libia
siria y sobre todo en adorno caravanas
por parte del socio estratégico
azerbayán que fueron muy destructivas
contra el ejército armenio en los
primeros compases de la guerra sí que es
verdad que estos drones fueron muy
letales contra los las posiciones rusas
porque porque los avances rusos se
hacían sin tener sin tener armas
antiaéreas y fueron digamos que muy
precipitados pero sin embargo ahora
están diciendo los generales que estas
distorsiones no están siendo tan
efectivos como antes quiere decir que
están los rusos ahora mismo están en una
posición en el que tienen armas
antiaéreas muy potentes y armas anti
drones que están logrando incapacitados
sigue siendo un arma bastante fuerte no
tanto desde el terreno a lo mejor de
golpear con bombardear pero si de
reconocimiento de las posiciones intenta
reconocer las posiciones rusas e
intentar a lo mejor lanzar artillería a
esas posiciones en ese sentido yo creo
que es un arma muy interesante y también
todo porque no es tampoco es muy cara de
realizar los los turcos tienen capacidad
para fabricar muchos drones no
evidentemente no son tan de alta
tecnología como los estadounidenses que
son mucho mejores pero tienen más
capacidad para que sean para enviar
muchos más además la diferencia de
precio un dron turco cuesta alrededor de
5 millones de dólares un drone
estadounidense cuesta 26 millones de
dólares aproximadamente y hay que decir
que la persona que lo diseñó la persona
que estaba encargada o al frente de este
proyecto del desarrollo de los drones
turcos es el yerno del presidente
erdogán y es visto casi que como un
héroe nacional en ese país por el
desarrollo de esta tecnología
erika pasemos ya hablamos de la relación
con con ucrania hacemos ahora la
relación con moscú lo que yo mencionaba
al principio en la introducción ucrania
perdón turquía es ahora el destino de
las fortunas
a dónde están llegando muchos de los
exiliados es prácticamente la única
puerta de entrada que tiene rusia hacia
el resto del mundo porque es el único
país con el que tiene habilitados los
vuelos comerciales entre estambul y
moscú y san petersburgo esto no puede
generar complicaciones a nivel
internacional debido a las sanciones que
tiene rusia en términos financieros y de
movimientos estratégicos a nivel
internacional
claro que sí todo dependerá de cómo se
desarrolle de aquí en adelante el
conflicto es cierto que hay muchos
observadores que dicen que este
conflicto no puede rebasar el otoño no
porque entonces entraremos al invierno y
se vuelve todo infinitamente más
complicado por las bajas temperaturas
etcétera y porque ya hay cierto
agotamiento de quienes están apoyando la
posición de ucrania sobre todo las
opiniones públicas que están viendo por
subir los precios
escasear los alimentos etcétera entonces
eso está va a ser complicado si esto se
alarga demasiado en todo caso yo creo
que la lectura de turquía es que lo que
no quiere que pase definitivamente es
que esto deje de ser un conflicto de
rusia con ucrania y pase a ser un
conflicto de la otan con rusia
lo cual lo pondría en un aprieto
monumental porque si como ya se había
dicho depende de rusia en muchos
sentidos ha servido para
para que no quede totalmente aislada
rusia tiene ahora fondos de los rusos
guardados en bancos turcos etcétera pero
el problema para turquía también está en
si van a lograr ellos mismos mantener la
estabilidad de su propio país de nuevo
la crisis es fuerte dentro de turquía
son muchos los años que lleva ya
gobernando ervan se sabe positivamente
que hay oposición fuerte erdogán aunque
no puede ser tan vocal como como debería
por las duras medidas que ha puesto en
marcha el propio presidente turco
entonces creo que también va a necesitar
poner eso sobre sobre la balanza y
decidir pues en qué posición va a
terminar eligiendo porque al final creo
que lo que más le interese erdogán es
seguir gobernando turquía no eso es lo
que lo hace el hombre fuerte que soy
claro ya vamos a analizar el tema
interno turquía de cara esas elecciones
presidenciales y parlamentarias que
tienen los próximos meses pablo le
pregunto ahora por en esta discrepancia
que hubo por el ingreso de suecia y
finlandia puso en jaque esta decisión
esta incorporación
algo que llamaba la atención por lo
menos de este lado del atlántico es como
este país que aparentemente no tiene
mucho peso en muchos votos y decisiones
dentro de la otan logró poner a esto
thalberg a negociar con erdogán frente a
frente y decirle bueno que necesitamos
para que turquía dé el visto bueno sin
embargo ankara sigue diciendo que todo
sujeto a como finlandia y suecia cumplan
con los protocolos
bueno es que como he comentado antes tú
quieres un país o está muy importante es
uno de los mejores ejércitos que tienen
la otan y no solamente eso sino que es
como se ha dicho ya varias veces es una
puerta de entrada de entre es un puente
entre asia y europa que es una posición
privilegiada y luego evidentemente
turquía ha sabido ganar mucha más
influencia en los últimos años gracias a
esa política asertiva que ha tenido en
tanto en síria en libia en el caso y se
ha demostrado una potencia a tener en
cuenta y por eso mismo está luchando
ahora mismo por digamos no tanto porque
de verdad le moleste que entre suecia y
finlandia la otan sino porque quiere
ganar algo a cambios es muy consciente
de que en este tipo de cuestiones se
pueden ganar cosas y sobre todo turquía
está también está pasando por un mal
momento económico también le ayudaría a
tener digamos algunas victorias en el
sentido por parte de a lo mejor el
sentir en el norte de siria como anuncia
de esa operación inter pero también a lo
mejor que incluso que la otan le ayudase
económicamente al país para que para que
esa caída de la liga que estamos viendo
no fuese tan dura dice que ésta está la
cuestión que es un país muy importante
pero también que es un país que sabe es
consciente de que necesita una serie de
prerrogativas para digamos para
venderlas de cara al público y así
digamos de ganar más y más digamos ese
efecto bandera que hay en turquía cada
vez que realiza una operación militar o
digamos deja ver su poder como pública
en política exterior
pasemos ahora al tema interno para este
último tramo del programa de cómo está
la situación ya hemos hablado de esta
crisis económica que está atravesando el
país la inflación altísima no es un
escenario nuevo turquía ya ha enfrentado
escenarios de inflación alta incluso de
hiperinflación pero lo que más o menos
ha logrado mantener la economía es
justamente la llegada de turistas rusos
y ucranianos o personas que han llegado
a vivir a este país que han traído
dinero para comprar e inmuebles y eso
mantenido un poco la industria turística
poco a flote por lo menos en este verano
y ha salvado un poco digamos la
temporada que es algo que le interesaba
mucho al sector turístico turco pero
internamente hay mucho descontento hay
miles de ciudadanos turcos abandonando
el país hay una fuga de cerebros
considerables de ingenieros científicos
y médicos buscando mejores condiciones y
sobre todo se sienten presionados por el
gobierno por por no compartir muchas de
las posiciones que tiene el gobierno de
erdogán cómo está el clima erika al
interior del país de cara a esas
elecciones que se le vienen al
presidente erdogán para mantenerse en el
poder
pues creo que turquía le está pasando
por un momento que podríamos poner es
semejante también a muchos países en
américa latina' etcétera de decir bueno
tenía todo este país para seguir la
senda que había marcado atatürk para más
bien ser más occidental que oriental
para para sumarse al avión europea en un
momento dado para hacer un país no
solamente estratégico geográficamente
sino que hubiera podido tener también
gran importancia en términos de
democracia en términos de apertura en
términos de capital humano de formación
porque finalmente las instituciones
turcas tenían muchísimo prestigio el
problema ahora es que lo que tienen es
este hombre fuerte
insisto no es un mal de turquía es un
mal mundial global un problema de
populismo severo en el mundo que está
coartando las libertades que son ya
muchos años una presión y un
hostigamiento terrible académicos
científicos periodistas
que están teniendo que alzar la voz en
la medida de lo posible dentro de
turquía o que han optado por salir al
final eso es una tremenda sangría de
capital humano y que pone en riesgo el
futuro el futuro turco finalmente el dow
and lo que lidera es un gobierno cada
vez más ideologizado cada vez más
fundamentalista cada vez más cerrado a
otras opiniones
cada vez de más mano dura y por eso le
interesa tanto lo que dar en el caso de
esta crisis de esta invasión rusa de
ucrania
una pieza clave como un nombre que no
permite que la otan le diga lo que tiene
que hacer los titulares que han saltado
medios sobre todo de ese lado del mundo
son de pues ya no es el mandado de la
otan de turquía gracias a erdogán que se
está resistiendo y no olvidemos que al
final lo que ha mencionado sobre suecia
y finlandia y sobre todo suecia es el
tema de que dar refugio a los del
partido de los trabajadores del
kurdistán y a los guionistas no lo cual
revela que hay mucho del pleito interno
turco en las razones detrás o sea y
mucho lo que quiere ganar de esta
apuesta y de este test a lo mejor es un
blog no creo que al final está poniendo
a todo el mundo contra las cuerdas en un
momento en el que todo el mundo está ya
muy nervioso de todas formas en su
opinión pablo
sí bueno la oposición a ortega ha ido
creciendo en los últimos años primero de
todo desde sobre todo desde el año de
2006 que es cuando se produce ese
intento del golpe de estado contra el
presidente
erdogán ahí comienza a poner en marcha
una autocrítica ción que es el que
comienza a verse volverse más
autocrático hacer una limpia tanto en el
ejército como en la administración
incluso en las instituciones financieras
etcétera y el ajuste en el sector de la
justicia y empieza a poner más acciones
a los suyos a tener digamos a
democratizar el país poco a poco lo que
pasa es que ese se ha unido a que la
situación económica y social es muy
precaria y eso ha hecho que la oposición
crezca de hecho las últimas las últimas
municipales el partido a partido a que
perdió la perdió las elecciones de
estambul y hay que decir que todo venía
de ser antes de ser presidente era
alcalde
de estambul eso hay que tenerlo en
cuenta y ahora lo que pasa es que está
viendo que su posición es cada vez más
precaria y quizás década 2023 esté
buscando un golpe de efecto que vuelva a
lanzarse las encuestas veremos qué pasa
porque todo va unido también a como
económicamente va a estar el país
teniendo en cuenta que estamos en una en
un momento de crisis de inflación de
crisis energética
está en un momento bastante precario
para percibir la verdad en pablo desde
su punto de vista y como ya lo han dicho
ustedes este es un juego de intereses
por encima de los valores y la capacidad
moral
están de pronto organismos como por
ejemplo la otan esta alianza militar
internacional o la unión europea
dispuestas a ponerse un poco la mano en
los ojos y olvidar temas como por
ejemplo los derechos humanos los
derechos de las minorías en turquía la
participación que han tenido y todas las
críticas internacionales en síria en el
conflicto de nagorno karabakh volviendo
a poner a armenia contra el paredón
y aceptar el flujo de estas elecciones y
que dogan permanezca en el poder y que
siga jugando como una pieza clave en el
conflicto de ucrania simplemente por el
interés occidental
bueno hay que entender sobre todo que la
moral no rige las relaciones
internacional es inmoral es ahora no
regido nunca otra cosa es la narrativa
que se puede decir desde desde los
países otan también hay que tiene en
cuenta que la otan es una alianza
militar defensiva y ofensiva que decir
no es una ong que busque la democracia
en los países exteriores o incluso
interiores hay que tenerlo en cuenta lo
que lo que básicamente lo que yo creo
que le puede interesar a la otan
evidentemente estrelló en turquía a
alguien que sea un aliado fiable puede
ser erdogán ese socio fiable no lo tengo
muy claro porque como hemos visto
balancea mucho con rusia pero claro a lo
mejor que turquía se derrumbe o que
tenga un otro socio puedes resultar en
que ese país se burlen de inestable y
entonces estamos hablando de un país que
hace frontera exterior con la unión
europea y que guarda millones de
refugiados y tiene intereses en
capitales en muchos países tampoco
interesaría una desestabilización de ese
país habría que buscar un equilibrio
entre intentar contentar a erdogán por
una parte pero sin digamos darle todo lo
que pide porque a lo mejor se puede
crecer
pero tampoco intentar digamos presionar
excesivamente al país para que no
quiebre por así decirlo porque también
están bastante precarias creo que
también la otan debe buscar ese
equilibrio y el descontento social pesa
mucho acá y los turcos han salido a las
calles en algunas ocasiones a mostrar
ese descontento y ya lo largo de la
historia lo han hecho y también es un
país que ha vivido escenarios de golpes
de estado
seguidos y no es un escenario adverso
para los turcos erika su opinión sobre
esta venda que se puede poner occidente
simplemente para dejar que ayude en el
tema de ucrania y olvidarse de temas de
derechos humanos
todo esto que está conversamos con pablo
bueno como bien dice pablo los ojos se
cierran cuando conviene o sea finalmente
eso ha pasado ya en ocasiones muchos
dicen incluso que el acuerdo que tiene
la unión europea con turquía para darle
dinero a cambio de que no deje pasar los
refugiados pues moralmente es
condenables y no no parte del respeto
pleno a los derechos humanos las
libertades y demás
creo que es cierto que van a buscar que
no se desestabilice turquía porque ya
sería la guinda en el pastel no ya sería
una crisis más y de nuevo en una zona en
una zona clave es cierto que turquía
también es un país grande
diverso
que tiene grupos distintos que lo
componen y en ese sentido la posibilidad
de caer en la inestabilidad en caso de
que no se pueda mantener el poder que
haya un nuevo intento de golpe de estado
que la situación económica política y
social reviente pues pues claro que esa
posibilidad existe que podría ser muy
peligroso sobre todo para europa y desde
luego para los aliados de la otan ahora
como bien dice pablo capital es una
alianza militar y aquí lo que cuenta es
el peso que tiene el ejército turco en
su posición geográfica y los recursos
que pueda aportar a la organización
además que es uno de los socios más
antiguos así que difícilmente le van a
hacer el feo
por por sus políticas internas en este
momento y occidente ha dejado de lado
algunas cuentas pendientes con turquía
por ejemplo el tema de la república
turca del norte de chipre este país
sigue dividido también la cuestión del
genocidio armenio es otra deuda
pendiente que sólo algunos países pues
han reconocido a nivel internacional y
les sigue pensando esa deuda histórica a
la turquía actual pese a haber sido un
hecho ocurrido desde hace muchísimos
años para el cierre del programa quiero
entonces hablar las conclusiones de lo
que puede llegar a suceder con este país
y también de cara a ese 2023 que es un
año muy significativo lograrán
consolidarse como ese país internacional
importante que ellos buscan y que han
tratado de enfocar todos sus esfuerzos
eric a su conclusión de lo que pueda
pasar con turquía en este escenario
overture quien no deja de ser una
potencia media en lo que pasa es gracias
a su posición geográfica su pertenencia
a la otan su capacidad militar etcétera
puede pegar golpes por encima de su
categoría del boxeo digamos
pero no hay que olvidarnos de que es
potencia media al final por ejemplo no
está ningún gran grupo digamos no es que
7 no es fritsch está en mixta no con
méxico indonesia corea y australia
pero bueno mi cta no deja de ser
exclusivamente un espacio de diálogo y
no más yo creo que por eso turquía busca
en la política exterior proyectar una
fuerza más allá incluso de sus propias
capacidades y también hay que decir está
involucrada en demasiados temas también
con respecto al exterior decíamos es una
ventaja lo que ha hecho en libia en
siria etcétera pero bueno también está
demasiado involucrado en conflictos que
no han terminado del todo entonces si
sumamos el conflicto interno la crisis
interna la situación tensa internamente
pues
pinta para hacer una segunda mitad de
2022 complicada para turquía y sobre
todo 2020 pesar si está en muchísimos
escenarios a nivel internacional y
ejerce ya una fuerza y una presencia en
la zona balcánica y en la zona del medio
oriente y del cáucaso que es bastante
considerable pablo su conclusión para el
cierre
yo opino que eventualmente evidentemente
finlandia y suecia en la otan que
haremos para atender a las
peticiones de turquía quizás no al cien
por cien pero sí que evidentemente
turquía sabe que no puede tensar la
cuerda eternamente y que no puede tensar
la mucho porque al final le interesa que
que la otan siga sus demandas y que al
final no sancione la previsible futura
operación militar en el norte de siria
yo creo que tú quieras' seguirá siendo
un jugador muy importante pero queda por
ver en qué estado está el país en 2023
si la situación internacional económica
y social es tan precaria como se predice
puede que turquía la crisis le pegue más
fuerte de lo que desearía al presidente
y ya lo mejor sí que es verdad que
podría tener posibilidades no quizás a
lo mejor de perder poder pero de ir
perdiendo poco a poco esa digamos esa
ese poder entre la gente que tenía o
incluso dentro del país es decir que
poco a poco voy a disminuye ese poder yo
diría que depende mucho de cómo se como
sea como acabe la guerra nuclear y cómo
se vaya viendo esa inflación y esa
crisis alimentaria y esa esa crisis
energética creo que eso depende mucho
del país como dichas por situación muy
precaria la misma pues paulo américa les
agradezco mucho por este análisis para
la audiencia de france 24 sobre turquía
este país que pues es muy lejano a
nuestra realidad en américa latina pero
no tenemos presidente desde las noticias
y los hechos internacionales está muy
presente en los diferentes conflictos y
hechos y mesas de diálogo a nivel
internacional muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros y ustedes gracias
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]